disparue au début de l'année dernière
georges aux 10 au sable lui aussi plus
grand mort que vivant
on n'a jamais autant évoquer ces
écrivains d'abord marginale à qui l'on
doit une dizaine de livres et dont
certains les romans policiers en
particulier ont connu une grande faveur
public son personnage familier de
l'inspecteur fabio montale commises au
d'origine italienne et la ville de
marseille principale protagoniste de ces
histoires sont devenus des références
gallimard et édith dans sa collection de
poche folio policier la trilogie de jean
claude izzo
voici un extrait significatif de son
premier volet total khéops
il passe à l'après midi à repérer les
lieux monsieur charles comme on
l'appelait dans le milieu habitait une
des villas cossues qui surplombe la
corniche des villas étonnante avec
clocheton ou colonnes et des jardins
avec palmiers lauriers roses et figuiers
quitter leurs casques blancs la rue qui
serpente à travers cette petite colline
c'est un entrelacs de chemins parfois à
peine goudronnée il y avait pris le bus
le 55 jusqu'à la place des pilotes en
haut de la dernière côte et puis s'il
avait continué à pied
il dominait la rade de l'estac à la
pointe rouge les îles du frioul du
château d'if marseille cinémascope une
beauté il aborda la descente face à la
mer il n'était plus qu'à deux villes de
celle du cas comme on le devine un crime
va suivre et puis j'ai une enquête et sa
conclusion iso sait parfaitement
raconter tout cela mais ce n'est pas là
la singularité de son talent ce qui
transperce
ici c'est une sensibilité qu'il laisse
apparaître lisez par exemple la
description qu'ils nous offrent de lol
la gitane si brune dans son peignoir
jaune paille et oser venir me dire
qu'elle ne vous donne pas la chair de
poule